The fighting between Israel and Hamas is the
worst we've seen since 2009 in Israel.
What began as a limited conflict has escalated
into a major Israeli ground offensive into
Hamas-held Gaza. It's resulted in hundreds
of deaths. Here's what happened and what it means.
It started with the murder of 3 Israeli young
men in the West Bank. They were students.
They were kidnapped and killed.
Israel responded to this, because it believed
that the killings were done by Hamas operatives.
It arrested a large number of Hamas people
in the West Bank and launched airstrikes into
Gaza.
Palestinians from Gaza fired rockets in response.
Israelis were furious and a Palestinian boy
was murdered by 6 Israelis, essentially, from
what Israeli police say, as an act of revenge.
Moreover his cousin was beaten in Israeli
police custody.
This led to a wave of anger on the Palestinian
side. On the morning of July 8, Hamas launched
a wave of 40 rockets in the direction of Israeli
towns with very little guidance or aiming.
They don't often hit targets or produce many
casualties but nonetheless create a climate of terror
inside Israel. These rocket attacks were the first that Hamas had claimed responsibility for since 2012,
the last major conflict. In response, Israel
launched more strikes in Gaza, as part of
what Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
said was an effort to make Hamas pay a heavy
price. By July 11th, 100 Palestinians had been killed by about a thousand airstrikes. By July 14th,
the total casualties had exceeded the 2012
conflict.
And then on July 17th, Israeli troops entered
Gaza to root out tunnels into Israel that
would allow Hamas to strike Israeli targets
or send soldiers in on the ground to attack
Israeli cities or military bases. After the
ground offensive, casualties have skyrocketed.
We've come a long way from 2009 when the Obama
administration came into office thinking they
could get the two sides on the same side,
that is, get a peace agreement done. Let alone
the heady optimism in the 90s that we saw
about Irael-Palestinian peace.
The sad path that led to an incredibly devastating
ground offensive in Gaza has illustrated just
how hair-trigger the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
is. Even slight provocations, even things
that may not be planned by one side or the
other one, can lead to massive escalations
in violence. There's just too much mistrust
and too much division to be able to solve
these problems any time in the near term.
And that's the sad truth of this conflict.